[Musique]
on retrouve Véronique Jonathan Trudeau
bonsoir elle est Castonguay bonsoir
bonsoir c'est pas une question d'argent
les maternelles 4 ans Véronique je
commence avec vous puis j'ai les
chiffres en plus devant moi de
l'auto-québec et de Hydro-Québec
ensemble c'est quasiment 5 milliards
qu'on donne l'État québécois mais tout
ça pour dire que ce n'est pas voici un
cas où ce n'est pas une question
d'argent ni de volonté manifestement
c'est une question d'organisation puis
personnelle le matin ils arrivent pas
l'organiser Véronique dès le départ en
2018 quand François Legault avait mis
son siège en jeu sur cette promesse là
parce que c'était une promesse fort déjà
à ce moment-là il y avait des drapeaux
rouges qui étaient élevés des
différentes associations des gens du
milieu de l'éducation qui disaient on
n'est pas contre les maternelles 4 ans
mais on vous dit tout de suite que vous
allez probablement manquer de locaux que
vous allez probablement manquer
d'enseignants ou d'éducatrices puis en
même temps à Patrice j'ai remarqué un
certain changement dans les cinq
dernières années au niveau du focus de
François au fur et à mesure qu'il essaie
de développer les maternelles 4 ans
rappelez-vous son ministre responsable
de la famille Mathieu Lacombe qui est
sorti du champ gauche en disant le
système des CPE le réseau ne fonctionne
pas du tout François Legault et son
équipe ne s'attendait pas à cette sortie
là et ça leur force à rediriger de
l'énergie et des efforts vers les CPA
parce qu'en plus les parents le
demandaient donc vous allez me dire l'un
n'empêche pas l'autre c'est à dire qu'on
peut développer les deux parallèlements
puis probablement oui c'est vrai là mais
j'ai remarqué quand même que François
Legault a mis énormément d'efforts sur
les CPE oui je vais vous le dire parce
que beaucoup de gens dans le réseau
disent c'est illusoire de penser qu'on
peut continuer à développer les CPAS à
plein régime puis en même temps à plein
régime les maternelles 4 ans Jonathan
vous en êtes où devant ce sujet vous
avez entendu Royer qui il y tient
beaucoup encore lui il y a des
spécialistes qui croient pas facile quoi
moi je suis dessus à la base qui ont
toujours été favorables au concept des
maternelles 4 ans je pense qu'il y a de
la place pour ça je pense que peut être
favorable ça peut être favorable pour
des parents qui considèrent que c'est la
meilleure option moi au moment où les
maternel 4 ans ont débuté j'avais une
jeune fille qui entrait la maternelle
elle était un intro trop vieille si on
veut le mais nous on aurait fait ce
choix d'aller vers la maternelle le 4e
pour une meilleure transition et tout ça
donc sur le principe je suis favorable
par contre l'élément qui est fondamental
c'est les difficultés qu'on avait avec
le réseau des CPE pour faire une image
un peu simpliste pour les gens qui nous
écoutent à la maison c'est comme si vous
décidez de rénover votre sous-sol et qui
à mi-chemin vous demander à des gens de
venir vous aider tout ça mais je peux
vous dire bon on va construire un
cabanon aussi en même temps il aurait
fallu compléter le resto despe avant de
dire ben il y a un autre modèle aussi
qu'on veut mettre de l'avant et qu'on
espère qu'il va fonctionner donc il y
avait un espèce de demeure si on veut
que ce dressait devant Bernard drinville
devant le gouvernement et vous savez on
a souvent dit depuis l'élection de
François Legault que et ça dans
l'entourage de François Legault que ils
veulent profiter de la première année
maximum 2e année pour brasser des choses
sans regarder les sondages être capable
de brasser des structures mais je pense
que ça inclut aussi le fait peut-être de
renier certaines provinces de de
certaines promesses pardon de revenir en
arrière et ils étaient aussi bien de le
faire plus tôt que tard parce que
évidemment Bernard drinville quand il a
parlé à TVA hier c'était pas un ballon
là je disais il est son patron savait
qu'il allait dire ça et
on se dit qu'on se débarrasse du fameux
clip que roi va rejouer sur le débat
2018 qui met son siège en jeu on va
passer une mauvaise journée puis bye bye
après Alec
ouais mais en même temps ce n'est pas
capable de les créer ces fameuses places
là on pouvait vivre avec le mythe qu'on
va y arriver mais il est aussi bien que
quelqu'un me disent à un moment donné ça
va pas se produire au départ c'était
quoi c'était 5000 places c'était 5000
places en garderie on avait ramené ça
2600 voyant que ça allait être compliqué
d'en créer 5000 là je voudrais parce
qu'on arrive à 2000 dans quelques années
on va être chanceux donc la promesse ça
a pas mal diminué et en même temps c'est
correct dans la mesure où les classes
actuellement où elles sont créées où
elles ont été créées au tout début c'est
beaucoup dans des quartiers favorisés
vous savez les les écoles qui ont créé
le plus rapidement les classes de
maternelle 4 ans c'est les écoles
privées primaires parce que ça
permettait de fidéliser une clientèle
dès l'âge de 4 ans où on pouvait dire si
vous voulez aller dans notre école
primaire privée commencez par la
maternelle 4 ans eux ce sont des péchés
et il y en a dans toutes les écoles
primaires privées au Québec des classes
de maternelles
défavorisés c'est pas mal plus compliqué
parce que c'est là qu'il manque de prof
c'est là qu'il manque de techniciens
c'est là qu'il manque de classe alors on
peut bien continuer à développer le
réseau dans les endroits favorisés mais
si on est pour mettre une pause de toute
façon aussi bien l'annoncer puis dire
écoutez on a fait ce qu'on a pu
actuellement puis graduellement
maintenant on va y aller puis
effectivement peut-être complétons le
réseau des CPE qui lui ça fait des
années qui attend d'avoir ses places en
garderie et sur ce front là au moins il
y a des nouvelle on a créé un peu plus
de place en garderie qu'avant monsieur
Legault vous allez l'entendre quand il
veut aller vers la sagesse
il cite sa femme on va on va l'écouter
puis ensuite le chef du Parti libéral
est toujours en jeu mais écoutez moi ce
que je dis là c'est que je souhaite que
le plus vite possible tous les parents
et Axel maternel 4 ans maintenant comme
souvent mon épouse à l'impossible l'une
des tenues donc on va essayer de le
faire le plus rapidement possible
pour un 12 places maternelle 4 ans ça
vous coûte 1.2 millions pour un CPE 80
places ça vous coûte 2 millions une fois
que vous avez dit sur tout le monde a
compris madame la Présidente un point de
million pour 12 places 2 millions de 80
places oui agir d'eau mais pour tous nos
enfants ceux qui ont 18 mois jusqu'à 5
ans également c'est un échec la liste
est toujours de 50000 noms sur la liste
d'attente ce qu'on veut c'est d'offrir
le choix en des CPE des gardes de riz et
des maternelles 4 ans il y a des
avantages des deux côtés mais moi je
pense que c'est important d'être capable
d'offrir le choix aux parents qui ont
des enfants en difficulté de la
maternelle 4 ans puis pour moi
contrairement en partie libéral ça coûte
pas trop cher
bon alors c'est un jeu qui sera encore
exprimé mais disons on a brisé le
calendrier qui était totalement
irréaliste
Roxane maintenant on en reparle encore
aujourd'hui Alec non avant je vais vous
faire entendre monsieur Trudeau on lui a
vraiment posé la question monsieur
poignet vous demande de le faire mais en
30 jours que faites-vous sa réponse
ce qu'on veut depuis plusieurs années
c'est de fermer le chemin Roxane
la question c'est pas est-ce qu'on
devrait le fermer la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on a ferme ce dont on
a besoin c'est de renégocier l'entente
des tiers pays ce pour s'assurer qu'on
ferme au complet toute possibilité de
traverser irrégulier
avec le dossier politique a évolué la
réalité complexe a peut-être pas bougé
mais le dossier politique a évolué cette
semaine monsieur Legault on en parlait
plutôt cette semaine avec Véronique a
réussi à faire basculer le sujet dans
l'actualité canadienne
ouais
qui était essentiellement régional qui
se passait beaucoup en français depuis
quelques années
mettons où on s'en préoccupait pas
beaucoup au Canada anglais parce que
c'était une un goût de frontière au
Québec on sait devenu un sujet pendant
canadien depuis maintenant un petit
moment François Legault a réussi à
l'amener sur la scène nationale au point
où les premiers ministres des Maritimes
se sont prononcé cette semaine en disant
on peut accueillir davantage de
demandeurs d'asile envoyez-nous un
chèque
mais on peut s'en occuper davantage il y
a des municipalités du Sud de l'Ontario
qui reçoivent davantage qu'avant à
Niagara Falls d'ailleurs ça fait pas
trop leur affaire parce que 2000
chambres occupées par des demandeurs
d'asile puis la saison touristique s'en
vient et on a pas vraiment le goût de
perdre des touristes américaines
pour en commander les demandeurs d'asile
donc on commence à taper du pied en
disant on pourrait régler ça avant le
printemps donc la pression elle augmente
sur Justin Trudeau c'est pas les les
ultimatums irréalistes depuis à
poilievre le fermer en 30 jours le
chemin Roxane sur pas vraiment de bon
sens mais le reste de la pression qui
vient des municipalités maintenant
François Legault fait en sorte que je
sois Trudeau est obligé de se prononcer
sur le sujet malheureusement il y a pas
de porte-parole crédible en français la
chaîne Fraser le ministre d'immigration
parle pas assez bien français pour
donner des entrevues dans les médias
électroniques du Québec c'est un gros
problème depuis longtemps au
gouvernement fédéral à mon avis mais au
moins le Premier ministre de s'en
préoccuper davantage qu'est-ce que ça va
donner au-delà le mystère s'épaissit
comment on va être capable de régler ça
là on est bien malin celui qui sait
comment y arriver parce que c'est pas
simple parce que tu dis chiant que que
j'ai régulièrement avec mon ami
Christian Dufour qui dit c'est simple
mais Jonathan et Véronique scar répondu
monsieur Trudeau aujourd'hui puis je
vais vous entendre là-dessus c'est pas
si simple parce que la seule solution
qui le voit qui voit lui à temps a
raison c'est que les Américains nous
permettent de refouler tout le monde
partout sur la frontière donc vous allez
conserver les demandeurs de réfugiés ils
rentreront plus au Canada la frontière
terrestre mais pour ça faut modifier
l'entente est-ce que d'autres façons
est-ce que on peut je sais pas Jonathan
vous en êtes où
qui nous dit ça fait des années qu'on
veut fermer le chemin Roxane assez bien
il y avait peut-être juste oublié de
nous le dire qu'il y avait cette volonté
là parce que ce qu'on a jamais senti du
côté du gouvernement Trudeau c'est le
sentiment d'urgence et là ben clairement
il est bien il est bien présent avec
parler de de baffleau qui est de Niagara
Falls donc à la frontière qui fait des
pressions j'ai vu le maire de Carnois
aussi qui dit oh là là on a on a un
problème le ça arrive par plusieurs
centaines eux aussi c'est la capacité
hôtelière qui semble faire défaut qui
craignent la saison touristique au
Québec nous on est rendu ailleurs c'est
l'ensemble des services c'est le
logement c'est la santé c'est
l'éducation donc Justin Trudeau il a
raison lorsqu'il dit que le problème il
n'est pas il n'est pas simple on peut
pas tomber dans des dans des solutions
simplistes comme Pierre pauliev
omis de l'avant comme le Bloc québécois
semble parfois le mettre de l'avant
comme le Parti québécois aussi de le
faire le titre de dire on va aller des
on va aller distribuer des tracks dire
vous venez pas ici on a plus de place ça
n'a pas de sens moi je pense que la
meilleure avenue elle ça pense par la
renégociation de l'entente sur les tiers
mais c'est qu'on ne sent pas qu'il y
avait cette urgence là le probablement
que c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
tangible pour ajuster un Trudeau mais on
peut pas s'attendre à avoir une solution
demain mais en attendant il doit prendre
ses responsabilités remplir ses
obligations de bien appuyer de bien
entre autres desdommager les provinces
qui subissent et les municipalités parce
que le modèle est différent au Canada il
y a des avantages les deux municipalités
qui doivent casquer pour pour cette
situation là doit s'assurer de remplir
ses responsabilités délivrer des permis
de travail aussi pendant ce temps-là
alors on ne sait pas parce qu'il y a le
grand mystère c'est qu'un des ministres
avait dit on a une entente à portée de
main puis depuis il est tombé dans une
oubliette enfin piéton on s'excuse à
Dina non non mais Véronique ce qui est
sûr c'est que
même si Monsieur Biden puis on le
souligne depuis des jours et des jours à
beaucoup d'autres chats fouetter il
serait surprenant que Monsieur Trudeau
ne lui parle pas directement en personne
de ça quand elle va venir dans quelques
jours là
c'est sûr que il y a un jeu diplomatique
là qui est en train de s'installer et
puis probablement que Justin Trudeau
avait surtout l'intention et je pense
que c'est ce qui va faire quand même là
vous laisse surtout parler d'échanges
commerciaux avec Joe Biden peut-être que
ça venait très loin dans la liste le
chemin Roxane peut-être qu'il lui en
aurait même pas parlé François Legault
donc cette diplôme masculin se passe au
dessus de sa tête il y en a pas de
levier par rapport à ça et donc le seul
pouvoir qu'il a c'est cette pression
communicationnelle qu'il est en train de
mettre sur Justin Trudeau et vous voyez
que c'est vraiment orchestré par son
cabinet parce que chaque jour il y a
quelque chose de nouveau hier la lettre
au globet de mail c'était la version
électronique aujourd'hui vous l'avez vu
dans la version papier il y aura
probablement encore quelque chose demain
après-demain donc c'est une espèce
escalade qu'on est en train de faire
parce que c'est la seule possibilité en
ce moment quand François Legault et puis
ça veut dire en grosselette majuscule
oublie surtout pas te parler à Joe Biden
du chemin Roxane parce que nous on est
en arrière de ça très bien mais on peut
s'étonner à l'aide vous l'avez dit qu'il
y a pas un ministre fort qui vient
expliquer les tenants et aboutissants de
ça au Québec c'est quand même incroyable
témoin on fait un peu de pédagogie c'est
notre travail qu'on le fait puis il est
mais qui est pas porteur de ballon à
Ottawa qui explique
les la complexité de tout ça pourquoi si
on fait ceci si on fait cela sans les
Américains et qu'est-ce qu'on essaie de
faire et qu'est-ce qu'on essaie de faire
parce que tout à l'heure il y avait
l'ambassadeur des États-Unis au Canada
monsieur couronne qui est en entrevue
chez nos collègues de la CBC qui disait
vous savez l'entendre sur les tiers il y
a pas un officiel américain qui va vous
confirmer qu'on aurait négocie ça c'est
pas la tenté de nos priorités c'est pas
important ce qu'on veut négocier avec le
Canada c'est ça taquet à la source du
problème qui est la migration en
Amérique du de tous ces gens qui veulent
entrer au Canada aux États-Unis mais
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est quoi le
problème à la source qu'est-ce qu'on
essaie de négocier c'est qu'il y a
aucune transparence on a commencé
officiellement à parler de l'entente
avec les États-Unis d'après ce qu'on en
sait en 2018 on est rendu en 2023 ça
fait 5 ans qu'on négocie quelque chose
qu'est-ce qu'on négocie qu'est-ce qu'on
essaie d'aller chercher et ça on en a
aucune idée parce que le ministre qui
est responsable du dossier s'exprime
soit très peu sur le sujet et sinon pas
en français alors que c'est au Québec où
on a le plus de sensibilité par rapport
à ce sujet-là très bien un mot combien
de temps excusez-moi ok on a le temps
négociation avec Terre-Neuve hier ceux
qui étaient avec nous au Téléjournal on
a fait l'historique de cette entente de
1969 qui est très avantageuse pour le
Québec on viendra pas sur tous les
teneurs aboutissants mais le Québec en
deux mois achète à 0,2 et peut revendre
à 8 sous une entente
monsieur Legault Jonathan demain ils
vont souper ensemble et dis-moi
j'attends tes propositions je sors ton
chéquier là
on veut faire attention de ne pas
brusquer parce qu'on sait que les gens
ternaient internet labrador vont être
très très méfiants sont encore en colère
de de de cette entente là ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que on n'est pas
nécessairement en totale position de
faiblesse parce que là des gens disent
mais le Québec doit faire des
concessions bon François Lego déjà parlé
de la possibilité c'est une première
dans ma connaissance aujourd'hui
d'offrir des compensations financières
sur l'entente de ça 2041 si on a une
entente intéressante pour le
prolongement donc certains vont être
portés à quoi peut-être qu'on arrivait
qu'une espèce de position de faiblesse
des perspectives qui me laissent
entreprendre qui nous laisse entrevoirs
qu'on pourrait manquer l'électricité
mais oublions pas une chose ils sont pas
totalement position de force non plus du
côté de Terre-Neuve parce que si Québec
décide du jour au lendemain que 2041
c'est la fin de l'Entente ils ont de
l'électricité avant aussi là et là le
meilleur client le meilleur partenaire
celui qui a déjà des lignes de
construites c'est le Québec donc chacun
a beaucoup a gagné beaucoup à perdre
là-dedans donc je pense que François
Legault fait bien d'y prendre rapidement
mais c'est pas c'est pas demain laver
qu'on aura une entente non plus
Véronique on va entendre le
gagnant-gagnant beaucoup là pour les
prochains mois oui c'est vrai en fait
que les deux ont des arguments qui sont
valables parce que d'un côté
du côté du de Enju fairy il peut très
bien dire il y a un sentiment d'urgence
à Québec moi je sens que François
Legault a absolument besoin de nous
parce qu'il se rend compte qu'il va y
avoir un manque d'électricité puis on
offre une puissance qui est très
importante du côté d'Hydro-Québec mais
en même temps Québec de son côté dit
c'est non seulement une petite province
qui peut peut-être pas gérer ce risque
là de projet elle a été déficitaire
longtemps là peut-être qu'il est en
surplus en même temps il y a eu de
l'aide du gouvernement fédéral donc
c'est une province que pas non plus
effectivement les lignes de transmission
comme le disait Jonathan donc chacun des
arguments valables mais François Lego va
se battre contre l'émotivité de ce
dossier là parce qu'elle vous ferez lui
c'est là-dessus là qui va miser pour
montrer à son électorat qui va les
défendre puis voyez leur chercher le
meilleur cette fois-ci Alex la prochaine
fois vous aurez un mot la ligne va
couper la parlant d'électricité c'est
terminé j'ai poussé l'eau à l'extrême ce
panel merci Véronique Jonathan avec au
revoir